[Music]
a few dozen hours can affect the outcome
of whole lifetimes and that when they do
those few dozen hours like the salvaged
remains of a burned clock must be
resurrected from the ruins and examined
this is the premise of Arundhati Roy
1997 novel the god of small things set
in the town in Kerala India called a
minim the story revolves around
fraternal twins
Rahil and esther who are separated for
23 years after the fateful few dozen
hours in which their cousin drowns their
mother's illicit affair is revealed and
her lover is murdered while the book is
set at the point of Rahel and Esther's
reunion the narrative takes place mostly
in the past reconstructing the details
around the tragic events that led to
their separation
Roy's rich language and masterful
storytelling earned her the prestigious
book of rise for the God of small things
in the novel she interrogate the culture
of her native India including its social
mores and colonial history one of her
focuses is the caste system a way of
classifying people by hereditary social
class that is thousands of years old by
the mid 20th century the original four
castes associated with specific
occupations have been divided into some
3,000 sub castes though the caste system
was constitutionally abolished in 1950
it continued to shape social life in
India routinely marginalizing people of
lower castes in the novel Rahel and
ester have a close relationship with
Volusia a worker in their family's
pickle factory and member of the so
called untouchable caste when Volusia
and the twins mother ammu embark on an
affair they violate what Roy describes
as the love laws forbidding intimacy
between different castes Roy warns that
the tragic consequences of their
relationship would lurk forever in
ordinary things like coat hangers the
tar on roads and the absence of words
Roy's writing makes constant use of
these ordinary things bringing lush
detail to even the most tragic moments
the book opens at the funeral of the
twin
half British cousin Sophie after her
drowning as the family mourns Lily's
curl and crisp in the hot church a baby
bat crawls up a funeral sari tears drip
from a chin like raindrops from a roof
the novel forays into the past to
explore the characters struggles to
operate in a world where they don't
quite fit alongside their nation's
political turmoil amou struggles not to
lash out at her beloved children when
she feels particularly trapped in her
parents small-town home where neighbors
judge and shun her for being divorced
the Luther meanwhile balances his affair
with R mu and friendship with the twins
not only with his employment to their
family but also with his membership to a
budding communist counter movement to
Indira Gandhi's Green Revolution in the
1960s the misleadingly named Green
Revolution introduced chemical
fertilizers and pesticides and the
damming of rivers to India while these
policies produced high-yield crops that
staved off famine they also force people
from lower castes off their land and
caused widespread environmental damage
when the twins returned to I'm enemies
adults the consequences of the Green
Revolution are all around them the river
that was bursting with life in their
childhood greets them with a ghastly
skulls smile with holes where teeth had
been and a limp hand raised from a
hospital bed as Roy probes the depths of
human experience she never loses sight
of the way her characters are shaped by
the time and the place where they live
in the world of the god of small things
various kinds of despair competed for
primacy personal despair could never be
desperate enough personal turmoil
dropped by at the wayside shrine of the
vast violent circling driving ridiculous
insane unfeasible public turmoil of a
nation keep probing the depths of the
human experience with these animations
you
[Music]